the heat wave continues it does really
pose a threat to anyone outdoors and
it's especially dangerous for those
struggling with homelessness mary jane
belliesa joins us live in studio tonight
with more on the help available here
mary jane oh well sasha definitely
temperatures are expected to spike to
107 and 110 this week making heat
exhaustion and heat stroke even more of
a risk if you're outside
for those living out on the las vegas
streets the need to find shelter becomes
a race against time when it comes to the
extreme heat although it wasn't las
vegas it was phoenix arizona a very
similar climate during the summer time
of course
and i in 1999 i was living on the
streets homeless so i come from that
background robert rozelle and adam
clausen are the founders of rise village
both men were once homeless and now
provide transitional housing for those
leaving prison they know all too well of
what those living on the streets go
through we were able to give out some
bottles of water
that's something simple you know that
anyone in the community can do
be able to provide a little bit of
relief but when temperatures hit
triple digits as they've as they've done
pretty consistently there's really not
too many options right we need to get
people off the street meredith spriggs
is the founder of carridet gardens the
non-profit helps homeless veterans find
jobs in housing she says not only is
shade and protection from the elements
important but so is staying hydrated
it's not uncommon to find people that
have fallen asleep and because the sun
moves
they get dehydrated and they die in
their sleep so we find bodies which is
unfortunate i always double check and
make sure someone's breathing
you know obviously you want to stay safe
so i would say call 9-1-1 if you think
somebody is in
distress
now due to the heat warning the city has
opened cooling stations across the
valley through tuesday